[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh of the grain
[Music]
flippy from indiana flippy from indiana
please unmute you are
on the air my friend hi can you hear me
yes i can
hey david it's me um i just was
wondering if you've ever reconsidered
making an only fans
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know
uh burning season is over and it's time
for you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
floppy dukes flippy floppy
five and a quarter inches all right so
uh
we're just going to cut it there whoa
what's going where's that even coming
from
[Music]
i don't even know what the song this is
oh here it is okay um sorry i'm gonna
cut it because we we just have too much
to talk about
this should be interesting today we're
gonna have a press briefing
with jen saki but she's bringing in
secretary of transportation pete
budegedge
and pete budej is known for dropping the
hammer
very aggressively when he appears on fox
news and people ask him stupid questions
like
sometimes he'll explain humans need
water to live
therefore plumbing is infrastructure
those are the types of things that mayor
pete will sometimes explain
so uh we're going to hear from him and
jenn saki
at the bottom of the hour and we have a
little bit of time to
go over a few things between now and
then i'm going to play so-called
normal voicemails as people often want
i have clips from the derrick chauvin
trial um
i have no unban requests today
so none of that which is fine which is
fine
um denver mccarthy just sent a super
chat saying david sir
did gutfeld run the hilarious cnn racism
gag
again last night thanks for your
coverage yeah i don't know if he did the
racism cnn bit
four nights in a row we know he did it
three nights in a row
unclear whether he went with it for the
fourth night in a row
maybe we will see uh one kind of funny
article
you maybe you've all been following the
matt gates fiasco
donald trump reportedly had to be talked
out of defending matt gates
because the allegations against him were
so serious
um this this is just so funny
a former president donald trump had to
be talked out of defending florida
congressman matt gates after reports
surfaced that the justice department
was investigating whether gates had a
sexual relationship with a minor and
broke federal sex trafficking laws i
guess trump was just
eager to get out there and defend him
that's according to new york times
maggie haberman who on thursday told
cnn's new day trump really wanted to
defend the lawmaker
but he was told to stand down because
the allegations against gates were so
serious
his first impulse was he wanted to
defend gates you know he's one of our
people
several of his advisers told him that's
a very bad idea that the nature of what
gates is being
investigated for is so serious that it's
not something former president trump
should be out there on a limb for
and speaking of which there was a
hilarious interview
with with the guy who was possibly matt
gates's
co-conspirator oh this is just amazing
stuff check this out
this is an interview with fritz sheller
now joel greenberg
is a guy that matt gates
may have been trafficking underage girls
with
we don't even know what's going on but
just listen to this and like
if if i'm joel greenberg i don't know
that i want this guy as my attorney it's
just not clear check this out
did your client introduce nat gates to
any underage girls
or secularly
all right so i'm just going to let you
sit down there
and so i can look over your head and
ignore that question
this is a lawyer guys i apologize
i i just can't answer that question i
wasn't okay
that was that was a little devious
you're hiding down there below and then
can you imagine uh here's another one
does matt gates have anything to worry
about does
matt gates that is such a brother
um when it comes to what happened today
does he
uh have anything
[Laughter]
and you're asking me right into the mind
of matt gates
right and uh well from your mind
from my mind
based on what my client knows okay
see i thought if i kept on talking and
talking i would avoid these questions
sort of sounds like tom arnold right to
say um
i'm sure matt gates is not feeling very
comfortable today all right
so that's uh i mean just everything
going wrong
uh for for i mean it's just it's crazy
what's happening it's really really
crazy what's happening
so that's the latest i guess with the
gates thing trump wanted to defend him
and then joel greenberg's lawyer is it's
all
it's all very very crazy i want to say
thank you to
jenny72 for sending in a twitch prime
sub
she sent it in via snail mail also
thanks to astro lycos for gifting a sub
poo stain pete very classy gifting
five subs and this is blood
signing up that's a total of eight
twitch subs right off the bat which i
really appreciate and then also extra
special
i want to say thank you to nathan quimby
nathan quimby just signed up at
joinpakman.com
using the coupon code better21 which is
still
one of the most popular coupon codes
on this side of the mason dixon line
let's put it that way
um hey david amazon bessemer results
came in they voted no
sad to see yeah i saw i don't know
enough about it yet to be able to say
so i'm gonna have to stand by stand back
and stand by chris says i like your
conversation on meet kevin great
interview oh yeah this is also funny
um i was interviewed by all star
realtor and youtuber kevin
paffrath and at one point i just to
entertain myself with the interview i
went full package
and this is just the full thing gets
published soon it's already on his
channel
check this out now the right argument
the republican argument right now seems
to be well let's do a
six to seven hundred billion dollar
package let's do that let's let's do the
infrastructure
but uh republicans are obviously heavily
opposed to
uh green and uh climate initiatives
energy efficiency standards you know
donald trump one of the big things he
did was
remove energy efficiency requirements or
at least some of them
for vehicles to say hey well if we lower
prices people can afford a new car and
that will increase average fuel
efficiency what's your stand on that
well listen for whatever reason
republicans seem
extremely intimidated by large packages
they have a tendency for small sometimes
very weak packages with terrible
performance
if you understand what i'm saying
reading between the lines here right
yeah
so um i i think that the games around
fine-tuning package size are less
interesting to me than fundamentally
what one's philosophical approach to the
role of government should be
because really it's not that if the
package is a little tinier
or it's a little flimsier republicans
all of a sudden
love it right it's they don't believe
fundamentally
that the government should be even
involved in this
many of them because they are such
extreme small government conservatives
so it's not even you know
package size they they try to flaunt
tiny packages i don't know what they're
bragging about quite frankly
right but i i i don't even think they're
talking in good faith quite frankly
gotcha yeah got it so it's it's really
more of just a contrasting argument like
there's there's not a small package to
be had that would
function as well as this it's just we
don't want you know two two let's how
about 600
that's exactly right the small package
is not going to work that well i think
you understand what i'm saying
nobody so there it is um so that was my
interview with kevin paffrath and the
full thing will be on my channel soon
and that was just a little bit of a
preview
that i published to my um instagram
i'm sorry to my twitter account thank
you i want to say thanks to astrolycos
and ky dizzle as well as green man and
grungy dan for the subs also
five gifted by ky dizzle that's nine
nine plus nine is uh wait a second hold
on
nine plus nine is eight carry the one
one eight eighteen
appreciate that very very much
um this is the point in the stream where
people say the coupon codes aren't
working the coupon codes are working
fine the
problem is people try to use the coupon
code on twitch you can't
people try to use the coupon code on
youtube you can't the coupon code only
works at joinpakman.com but it's working
fine
alex asking whether i golf it's a great
pandemic sport i haven't golfed in years
i
i threw out my golf clubs right in the
trash a couple of years ago because i
hadn't used them for so long and they
were kind of damaged
how did greenberg get jeff bridges to be
his attorney the dude abides yeah my
thoughts exactly
ryan says if we pass the spending
package to cover costs and legal help to
fix the roughly 10
of the voters issues with ids this would
mitigate much of the oppressive voter id
laws being passed do you agree so you're
saying pass voter id
and a spending package to get everybody
ids
haven't thought about that i'd have to
think about that
gutfeld only proves that conservatism
contributes nothing to art or culture
well said
dereten says rest in peace his royal
highness prince philip
duke of edinburgh yeah obviously we
never wish death on everyone i'm pretty
sure that
a lot of his family was was nazi
sympathizers
and i you know i i don't even want to
get into it i have nothing to say about
it
carrick says i got my first vaccine shot
a few days ago hopefully there's a light
at the end of the tunnel love the
content
let's hope so let's hope so
oliver says quick question regarding
yesterday's bonus show do you think
we'll see an increase in utah home
births
because of abusive biological fathers
pressuring women to avoid paying medical
bills
i don't think it'll be statistically
significant
all he had to say is i don't have
anything more yeah i know that that
it was surprising that greenberg's
lawyer was so
flummoxed by those questions okay
uh let's do do people want agitated
karen
wears a mesh mask do people want clips
from the derek chauvin trial
or do people want quote normal
voicemails not like troy york voicemails
or whatnot
any preference right now
or do people want me to announce fake
new memberships i could also do that
jack mayerhofer just got a new
membership
we'll start with the karen all right
let's start with the karen
i couldn't find the original video so
it's one of these react videos but i
guess this is
some kind of a completely it's like a
non-mask let me i haven't seen this
let's take a look
yeah it says face mask cover your uh
cloth kind of
regular grip
the mouth isn't covered though right i
mean it's just like a chin strap and a
nose bar
it's not really covering your mouth
there is absolutely none i don't see it
anywhere
and i don't see it anywhere on any of
europe it says
face mask is required
i mean it's like okay let's
keep going i even realized that it will
you turn to the side but it that
basically is like the
you know the net where you like clean
the fish i wish i had the original video
this episode
where um bart is like yo i'm gonna just
okay i guess the rest of it is just this
guy talking who's this this is doobie
duke sims
um all right well anyway this is a very
very stupid person that i think we know
for sure uh but
i guess that's it i guess that's the
entire thing i don't know
okay um conservative humor is as amusing
as crib death oh my god that's really
aggressive
new york times reports the warmongering
military industrial complex shilling
biden administration is close to
re-entering the iran deal
yeah uh i had a segment
along those lines a couple of weeks ago
let's look at um
let's look no guys the reason i didn't
look at the video first is
i can't i can't find the original video
if someone can tell me where the
original
original video is oh wait a second oh
original video look at this
hold on let's take a look now
sign up for tick tock oh my god you got
to be kidding me oh here we go
it says here we go
this is covering over my nose and my
mouth
no it's not there is no adequacy in a
face mask
there is absolutely none i don't see it
anywhere in the cdc guidelines and i
don't see it anywhere on any of your
it says a face mask is required
[Music]
yeah it says face mask cover your okay
read the bricks cdc all right well there
it is that's the original video a very
very stupid person
um scoring a visit scoring a point i
guess for
for freedom or something like that
thanks to milo wilde for gifting five
subs on twitch
very much appreciate that uh putting us
at 23.
all right let's look at some uh derek
chauvin trial clips
here is i haven't pre-screened these
here is
eric nelson derek chovin's attorney
suggesting maybe
covid was a reason for george floyd's
death let's listen
in terms of we also understand
that mr floyd had previously been
diagnosed with
coven 19 right correct and he may not be
symptomatic have been symptomatic on
march 25th
but it's fair to say that um a lot is
unknown about the effects of covid19
on a person's lungs long term i mean
not as much as it would appear to be the
case i mean because obviously it's a
viral in this we have a huge amount of
information about the long-term effects
of viral illnesses
and those can affect the elasticity of
the lungs right
not the elasticity it would be if it's
having any effect it would be within the
sensory receptors within the trachea
this doctor is not going for it so it
really wouldn't have anything to do with
the elasticity
okay now but we also learned quite a bit
about
the toxicology as well excuse me on the
coven 19 you testified
that um treatment of people with
covid19 includes leaving them in the
prone position right
oh my god is he going to suggest that
maybe the position they had
george floyd in was good for him because
it's
being face down is good this is crazy
and so those people who would be treated
for covet 19
in the prone position based on your
calculations you would have a
24 decrease in the eelv
right i mean this is people with covet
where they're
during the time that they have covert
right but
that's what you'd expect that's which is
not what george this this is
this is crazy decrease in the eelv
no it's going to be very different in
somebody who has
say pneumonia what's going to happen in
the prone position
will be very variable from one person to
another as a result
of the pneumonia it's different than
normal lungs okay
so so in essence every person is
different
oh for certain hey listen every person
is different so we can never really know
anything about why anyone died george
floyd may have had a condition
where uh at you know at exactly the time
of day
when he died uh people who are exactly
his height
spontaneously expire they just die if
they are talking to a police officer but
we don't know that that's not possible
it could have been
he'd be the only person with that
condition
and now uh you calculated
uh his respiratory rate to be 22
right and you said there could be george
floyd might just be a guy who has a
condition
where um if during daylight hours your
respiratory rate is 22 and you come into
contact with an officer
you die it's just it's so rare nobody
else has ever had that exact scenario
that was within the normal respiratory
rate
and um you would not describe him as
hyperventilating
the word hyperventilation is open to an
awful lot of misinterpretation that is
most certainly not hyperventilation
yeah okay so there's that um
here is dr william smock testifying
there's no evidence george floyd
had a heart attack here's another line
of questioning a few questions
about heart disease and
high blood pressure i want to bring this
home to
mr floyd and that is whether we're
talking about blockage of the artery
high blood pressure any of it
was there any evidence that you saw that
george floyd had a heart attack
there was absolutely no evidence at
autopsy
of anything that suggested that mr floyd
had a heart attack and that's whether he
had a clogged artery he didn't have a
heart attack
that is correct there's no evidence of a
blood clot
so this is this is good because they're
ruling out the other causes of death
that some are trying to attribute to
what happened
if there's no evidence of hemorrhage
from a ruptured plaque
there's no evidence that mr floyd had a
heart attack what about on the autopsy
report
was there any evidence that george floyd
had a heart attack no sir there was not
you asked questions about whether there
was a lethal or fatal arrhythmia
remember those i remember this sir if
somebody has a fatal arrhythmia that
they die from is that a sudden death
it is sir and then i have the arrhythmia
and that's it you have the arrhythmia
and then you're unconscious
uh did george floyd have a sudden death
that looked like an arrhythmia
no sir he had a gradual
decreased levels of oxygen over the
course of minutes
it wasn't sudden it was gradual because
of the pressure being applied
to his back and neck you you were asked
questions about uh mr floyd saying i
can't breathe when he was in the back of
squad 320. remember that yes sir did you
hear
or in any of the videos you saw mr floyd
is saying i'm getting choked no sir
uh did you see anything that suggested
that there's in the struggle in the back
of the car
that anybody had their hands on his
knackers room uh
not in the car mr showing did put his
hands around his neck
as he was getting him out of the car but
not in the car
right obviously if there is someone
getting choked that's the reason they
couldn't breathe
yes sir okay so then this continued
um dr smock continuing to
uh do it well i mean i don't know who's
doing dr smock is just answering medical
questions
it's it's the uh special assistant
attorney general jerry blackwell who's
really leading him through the questions
was there any evidence of low oxygen on
autopsy
only his death sir
do you recall mr nelson uh asking you
the question
relating to when mr floyd was on the
ground
was he alert and making sense when he
was on the ground remember that
yes sir i do if somebody is alert that
making sense
how could they also be intoxicated and
that's a good question sir you can't
and finally you ask questions about uh
the combination of meth and fentanyl
and so whether they make somehow a
different kind of a dangerous
combination just to be clear with the
jurors
did you see any evidence that mr floyd
died of a meth overdose no sir he did
not
did you see any evidence that he died of
a fentanyl overdose
no sir he did not did you see any
evidence putting them together that he
died from that kind of an overdose
no sir he did not thank you no further
questions
so this getting very very direct and
clear
um i think i might have a couple of
others
uh oh here's dr lindsay thomas saying
um if it were offend not only was so the
the that clip i just played for you is
there was no um evidence in autopsy that
there was a fentanyl or meth related
death now hear dr lindsey thomas
explains had it been a fentanyl overdose
it looks different than what took place
so in terms of the uh the video footage
then either ruling in a cause
or ruling out a cause uh how did it
inform your
your assessments about the cause of
death having looked at the video
well it helped me rule in
a cause and also rule out causes i would
say
so did it help you determine whether
this was uh what i might refer to as a
lights out
kind of death a sudden death right so
what i observed from
all of these videos is this was not a
sudden death
mr floyd did not it's not like the snow
shoveling where i told you
somebody comes in collapses and you know
clutches their chest and falls over
this wasn't there was nothing sudden
about his death so
that's what i would have expected if it
was a cardiac
arrhythmia or abnormal beating of the
heart typically those are
someone really
falls over pretty quickly and this was
not that
likewise it was not the type of death
that has been reported
in a fentanyl overdose for example where
someone becomes very sleepy and then
just sort of gradually
calmly peacefully stops breathing this
was not that kind of a death
so i felt comfortable ruling out
those as causes of death and then on the
flip side
you i could clearly see from watching
the video
what happens to mr floyd during this
subdual restraint and compression
and what happens to his breathing is
it gradually becomes more difficult and
then
stops so there is that and uh
there was one more i think um
okay there is no evidence to suggest
that george floyd would have died that
night
had he not had interactions with law
enforcement was there any evidence to
suggest
that mr floyd was suffering from a
potentially
fatal condition on the evening of may 25
2020
no
uh do you uh have an opinion
to reasonable degree of medical
certainty if mr floyd
would have died that night had he not
been subject to the
uh subduel and restraint of the police
there's no evidence
to suggest he would have died that night
except for
the interactions with law enforcement so
very very clear and definitive
statements there
um and you know i mean listen
i don't know what the outcome of this
trial is going to be you could you could
very well see
an acquittal um but what we are seeing
so far
multiple medical professionals
definitive about what we can rule out
and
and what we can rule in here okay i want
to say thanks to artisans uk
as well as hateful eddie for the twitch
subs thanks also to serif of lies and
hutch the beast
that's four putting us at 27.
we also continue to welcome
uh the usage of this uh legal but
borderline immoral coupon code immoral
21
usable at joinpakman.com i see a couple
of people on the membership page right
now so maybe i'll have a few
uh new member names to announce but the
coupon code
unpublished and available
is i guess so where where we would put
that other um
super chats that are coming in chakaseki
says when you were proned in the icu
typically you're intubated sedated and
have extensive physiologic monitoring
but hey
chavin's defense doesn't care yeah i
don't understand why so many people are
upset the officer has a defense
and isn't already sentenced to life in
prison that's how court works
absolutely what's the over under that
buddha judge
makes smurfmeister douchey cry yeah i
hope that peter steve douchey
asks mayor pete a question and that pete
puts him in his place
that would be good prince philip was the
first royal to visit
israel his mother is righteous among the
nations from yad vashem and he
personally fought nazis in world war
ii alright there is deretend
um okay and i guess i think we're caught
up there
as far as that goes um
okay so let me get now every once in a
while we like to go
on friday streams we will sometimes go
through
oh
okay we're standing by we will i think
this is peter steve douchey right here
we will sometimes go through quote
normal voicemails people like to hear
what kind of voicemails we get
let's see if we can listen to just a
couple of them
uh here's just just this is random
unscreened stuff
hi david viewer from indiana
um i know earlier in the week you had
talked about how at one point
um earlier in your career you had been
approached to do
conservative programming um which you
know would have netted you some money
but would have made you kind of uh
have to re you know kind of go against
um what you stand for
and i know today you had the clip of um
dan crenshaw with joe rogan right
and i i'm not overly familiar with joe
rogan so i don't know if that was a
typical show for him
um but it didn't seem like there was a
whole lot of pushback or critical
thinking applied
and i am just wondering if you feel
joe rogan at one point was offered a
similar deal
um no i have no reason to think that at
all
it's completely speculative uh
let's see what else we've got
here's another one hey david this is
daniel goodlow i called yesterday
talking about the uh j vaccine being
paused at the pnc arena
uh when i got my uh after i had gotten
my
vaccine dose yesterday um it seems like
the cdc came out said they didn't find
any safety issues with the batch
um i'm feeling absolutely fine outside
of some arm soreness
um and out of the the 2 300 people that
were
um well 2 300 plus people who were uh
vaccinated there yesterday only 18
people had adverse effects 14 people
were treated on site
no all right good good update as far as
that goes
um here's a we're just going random oh
no okay here we're starting there is
mayor pete
along with side gen saki let's listen
okay
so if it's another day we have another
member of the jobs
cabinet joining us today is
secretary uh buddha judge he served as
you all know
two terms as mayor of south bend indiana
where he worked
across the aisle to transform the city's
future and improve
residents everyday lives household
income grew
poverty fell unemployment was cut in
half he helped spark city-wide job
growth and facilitated innovative
public private partnerships like a
benefits
i know i like that transportation
experience for workers
one of the mayor's initiatives smart
streets led to benefits that included
small business growth
along previously neglected corridors and
hundreds of millions of dollars in new
private investment in the once emptying
downtown
he also served for seven years as an
officer in the u.s navy reserve
taking the leave of absence from the
mayor's office for a deployment to
afghanistan in 2014
and he is the first openly gay person
confirmed to serve in a president's
cabinet i know you know a few things
about him from the past
um he will take a few questions at the
end we kind of have a time limit so as
always
i will be the bad cop with that i will
turn it over thank you
pete boot edge edge let's see who he can
smack around here
thanks a lot jen and uh thanks everyone
it's a real honor to be here especially
at such an important and exciting moment
for the country i'm
convinced that this is the best chance
in our lifetimes to make a generational
investment in infrastructure
and that's what the american jobs plan
does the need is clear
it's growing by the day after decades of
under investment we have fallen to
13th place globally in infrastructure
delays caused by traffic congestion
alone
cost over 160 billion dollars per year
and motorists are forced to pay over a
thousand dollars
every year in wasted time and fuel
americans are spending too much of their
money on transportation in the wrong
ways
or don't have access to it at all and
the american people are making clear to
all of us regardless of party that they
want us to get it done
and they are not asking us to tinker
around the edges
we've risen to this challenge before as
a country in fact building bold
infrastructure has always been
central to america's story we built the
erie canal
we connected east to west through the
transcontinental railroad
and we developed the interstate highway
system and each of those projects was
audacious was transformative and
partly because it challenged the uh
american people to expand our concept
of infrastructure but in doing so these
projects transformed our nation for the
better
and they fueled the us economy and way
of life for the long run
so now it's our turn the american jobs
plan will again
transform america's roads and bridges
rail and transit
ports and airports for the better it's
going to help modernize our
transportation infrastructure so we can
compete in the 21st century and connect
communities
it will create millions of good jobs in
communities across the country
i want to point out again that this is
the biggest investment in american jobs
since world war ii
but i think it's important to demystify
the kinds of jobs that this plan is
going to create
these are good jobs they are not
mysterious or overly
futuristic or inaccessible we are going
to need workers who are good with steel
to make the cars and trucks
of the future we are talking about
building retrofits that are going to
require union
carpenters and insulators painters and
glazers we're going to need electrical
workers
more than ever we're not going to be
able to build the roads we need to build
without construction workers laborers
operating engineers plumbers and
pipefitters are going to be a huge part
of the story
of how we overhaul those lead service
lines so this is a jobs plan that is
building
america's economy from the middle class
out
coming at just the right time it's
meeting the challenges that we face
today
and it is fully paid for by making
corporations
to pay their fair share we think it's
unacceptable that there are
major profitable corporations in this
country paying less
in taxes than a teacher or a firefighter
not
in terms of a percentage but in terms of
dollars
specifically in many cases paying zero
and there's been a lot of talk at this
moment as you know about what
infrastructure is and isn't
i would argue that infrastructure is the
foundation
that makes it possible for people to
live and work well
and you can't live or work or thrive
without
things like roads clean water
electricity broadband yes that's
infrastructure
and investing in a full vision of
infrastructure is how we
build a safer and more prosperous
america and
ultimately i believe critical to the
american dream so
that's why i'm thrilled to be in this
role delighted by
the american jobs plan announcement and
spending time every day speaking to
stakeholders
about how to make sure we get it through
all right
hey here go ahead thank you president
says he wants 80
billion dollars for rail and the other
day he was talking about having trains
that can go across the country as fast
as a plane
i'm curious as the transportation
secretary do you see a big demand
for that for a high-speed cross-country
train well it's definitely a lot of
excitement around america about ensuring
that the american people can enjoy a
high standard of passenger rail service
like the president i don't think
americans should settle for less
than citizens in other countries enjoy
as a matter of course
now the truth is we have a backlog to
deal with in addition
to making sure that we can create new
routes and new capacities our train
system what's great about the scale of
the american jobs plan is it's going to
support
both of those things maintenance that
we've needed to do all along
and a chance to build new routes and
expand what americans can access
about how long away are we from
something like a high-speed
cross-country train
well again we need to add a lot first of
all
sadly 30 years but we can build new
routes with the resources that are here
it's not the end of the story but it's a
fantastic beginning for a new chapter in
american rail
josh um thanks for doing this as you
know there's been some criticism
about the corporate tax hike some people
have said that user fees should fund
infrastructure
and i was curious because user fees
often cover the cost of maintenance and
repairs
does this administration have a plan to
cover maintenance and repairs for all
the infrastructure
that's being built so as you know the
the jobs plan envisions this being
covered through
corporate taxes and the president
believes very strongly
that this is not something that should
burden uh
ordinary american families at a time
when we've got so many corporations that
have paid
literally zero and i also would argue
that there's
ample evidence that american
corporations can be competitive
uh at a tax rate like 28 for the simple
reason that they were extremely
competitive
at a tax rate like 35. and remember 28
of zero is not different than 21 of zero
lower would be lower than it's been for
most of my lifetime
now we've heard a lot of different ideas
on what the pay for should be i think
this is a good time to take
those inputs on board but for for my
dime it's pretty hard to beat
the vision that the president put
forward does there need to be a
dedicated revenue stream
well look we'll keep talking with
congress about this but as you know uh
for some time
we've seen general fund dollars going
into supporting maintenance so there are
a lot of different ways to do this uh
but the best way i've seen especially
for these kind of
capital improvements is exactly what's
in the president's plan
right mr secretary um
having covered local state and local
government for almost 20 years before
coming here i've seen the divisions that
can erupt in within the state between
regions of the state
over as they fight over limited pots of
money to
build these kinds of infrastructure
projects how
how involved do you think the federal
government the department of
transportation
congress the white house should be in
making the inevitable choices they're
going to have to be made
in terms of which bridge gets fixed
first
which road gets widened you know
there's obviously not enough money to
fix everything and to do everything and
so how how much of a role do you
envision playing or is it up to the
states to kind of
wage the wars they normally wage over
this time well i think there's always
been a push pull here right
because communities often know what is
most needed
for them and and we welcome that and i
think our program design
recognizes that so i view our role as
laying out the broad
policy strokes even in the existing
discretionary grant programs you've seen
this so for example with the infra
formally known as fast grants we made
sure that that that first wave of
calls for applications clarified that
we're looking for
great projects that also bear on things
like equity and climate that are
important to this administration
and you'll continue to see that in the
program design
of course there's always going to be
competition for limited funds but the
other thing i would say
is that competition is most ferocious
when the funds are most limited and so
part of what we're trying to do here is
make sure there's an ample
set of resources to go around so that
some communities uh may uh
be the most successful in in rounds of
competition but that it doesn't
uh feel like other computers or
communities are being left behind
because we've got to make sure there's
enough
uh to raise the bar in the country as a
whole just one quick follow-up on that
to the extent that then a lot of that
decision making gets pushed to the local
level because that's where they
they know that the you know how to how
to allocate the needs
how does the federal government retain
oversight of over
what is an enormous amount of money both
in terms of
you know just sort of waste fraud and
abuse but also in terms of making sure
that
um you know that it adheres to those
kind of
broader equity equity you know issues
that you guys talked so much about
yeah i mean that's a big responsibility
for a department like mine that'll be
charged with carrying this out and
the president has already made clear his
very high expectations for us
in the rescue plan dollars right that's
about 40 billion just out of the rescue
plan that we got to manage well
but you know he also rightly takes pride
in the remarkably low rate of
waste fraud and abuse in the uh in the
the recovery act
that he led in the obama administration
i think
now's a moment to make sure we double
down on those principles to make sure
that the dollars are well spent and yes
we got to make sure that they actually
meet the public policy goals that are
motivating us to do this in the first
place
secretary thanks for doing this um
although with you and chris here i'm
having an alternative universe
since you're a transportation secretary
travel obviously
a big part of what you have to worry
about to americans eager to get back
overseas
whether it's by plane or by cruise ship
uh you know there have been questions
about the cruise industry especially
this past week cdc issued some guidance
this time interested in concerns that it
perhaps didn't have enough specifics
or specific benchmarks i guess have you
been in touch with the cdc about that
industry's concerns
and to cruise industry leaders who say
we should be treated more like the
airlines
what would you say well the bottom line
is safety right
and we look on the secretary of
transportation i can't wait for us
all to be on the move as much as
possible in a safe and responsible way
but it's got to be safe and responsible
and airlines
have airplanes have one safety profile
cruise ships have another vehicles have
another and
each one needs to be treated based on
what's safe
for that sector i'll tell you i
certainly care a lot about uh seeing the
the
cruise sector thrive and i know that cdc
is hopeful
that a lot of these operators will be in
a position to be sailing by mid-summer
and uh laying out these specific kind of
gates that they need to get through
is a very important step towards the
idea of going on a cruise has never
appealed to me i have no interest
i want the industry to recover not for
me my friends
do this as soon as we responsibly can
but we also have to make sure that it's
safe
see once you get the money from the
rescue plan is there a process for
speeding the projects that you're
getting construction started because
there's always delays and permitting and
so forth
yeah this is uh another thing that i was
glad to see specifically
discussed in the jobs plan release which
is the importance of efficiently
delivering these dollars and we see that
a lot of countries
that have very rigorous standards around
environmental and other concerns also
have found ways to make sure the
delivery is efficient so
provided it does not entail cutting any
corners on things that are
fundamental policy goals and legal
requirements like you know environmental
standards
you know provided we can do it without
cutting corners i think we can find ways
uh to make sure that the process is more
efficient to look for duplication
and try to root that out and that's
going to be an important part of making
sure that
these dollars do the most good
economically although i would point out
this is not this is not the same kind of
stimulus pattern we were talking about
in 2009 right
we're looking for shovel worthy projects
we're also looking at shovel ready
projects but also
shovel worthy projects that are still in
that pipeline
okay um to pivot really quickly
to planes um there's been uh problems
discovered with the 737 max
dozens of them have been grounded and
this was months after the faa said they
were safe to fly again
i'm curious if you still have confidence
in the faa's decision
to uh lift the grounding of the jet good
question so my understanding and we're
we're just looking at this uh but my
understanding is that this is uh
different from any of those other issues
and that obviously that we need to make
sure that they are
there's full confidence before these
specific aircraft return to the air and
that's what the faa will be closely
monitoring
thank you mr secretary many
administration officials including
secretary granola yesterday
frame infrastructure in the context of
competition with china
so my question is why do that why design
and frame a policy based or in the
context of what an adversary is doing
i think because it's really important to
understand that american competitiveness
happens in a context
and when you see other countries our our
allies also our strategic competitors
doing more than we are it challenges
that fundamental idea that american life
is what it is
partly because america is in first place
in so many of
these uh aspects of our national life
only america is not in first place in
infrastructure like i said we're in 13th
so when you have a strategic i wish i
knew what that meant uh
investing sometimes multiples of what we
are in forms of transit i'm not saying
it's not measurable i just don't know
how you measure something so broad
content to be left behind or whether we
actually want to remain number one and
from iodine
there's no good reason why we should
settle for less
and why we should be content that it's
nothing against chinese citizens but i'm
not content that a chinese citizen can't
count on a dramatically better
standard of let's say train travel than
a u.s citizen i think americans should
always have the best and i think that's
the tone that the president
sets every day to follow up on that is
it partly also a messaging
strategy to get more republican support
well i'll say that i've heard
a lot of uh voices from across the aisle
also expressing concern about whether
america is
falling behind in any number of
strategic and economic
uh dimensions and again a lot of that
depends on
uh what we're investing and this is
nothing new right i mean
part of what made the interstate highway
system so important was an understanding
that our national security uh in the
eisenhower era was was was well served
by making sure that we had a more
connected economy
and country uh that we're not in the
cold war and this is not the eisenhower
era but that principle that national
security is at stake
applies especially when you consider
that today one of the biggest threats to
our national security
is the global security threat posed by
climate change
have you personally spoken with senator
manchin about this proposal
i'm looking forward to speaking with him
soon this next week or
i don't remember the date but i think we
got a conversation in the works and he
of course has an issue with the
corporate tax rate going to 28
is in his proposal his counter proposal
has been 25
can this plan be successful with a 25
corporate tax rate well
as you know the the maybe the flagship
piece that people are talking about most
is the rate but there's a lot of other
things alongside that
in terms of what's going on with the
loopholes the offshoring incentives and
other things
and i haven't had a chance to get a
sense of how he views those things
adding up whether he envisions
another element that makes up for the
gap between 25 and 28 those are the
kinds of things i want to take up with
him and
and get a have a good conversation on
because i think you know for anyone who
is
on board and by the way i have yet to
talk to anybody who
including in conversations with
republicans who is against the idea of a
big
investment in infrastructure right so
most of the dialogue we're having is
around how we're going to pay for it
and we're really eager to hear the
alternative suggestions for how to pay
for it and have republicans given you
so far alternative suggestions for how
to pay for it that you believe are
viable
uh not in any detail now
um just to follow up on what caleb said
because she actually asked my question
um
but um you would be opposed so you would
be um
willing to lower the corporate tax rate
in exchange for maybe closing additional
loopholes or
like the 28 is not a fixed rate that you
are
dead set up well we've heard the
president say that this is
going to be a process of negotiation
what's also interesting is he's the
transportation secretary so
the tax reform is not really even his
thing considered to be better than the
one the president put forward but
it's it's early in that legislative
process yeah why are they exactly yeah
people people pointing this out uh well
i've got a couple from people who can't
be
here today because of kv-19 restrictions
uh as they've been folded so first of
all
from chris mcgeary of the la times to
follow up on the high-speed train
question
how about california high-speed ram is
that a project that could be funded
through the infrastructure bill
potentially i mean i think it's
important to recognize that
communities of different types and in
each part of the country can benefit
from high speed rail or or even from
raising the standards of what most other
countries would consider
regular speed rail and their
availability here in the us
but this is not crafted in a way that's
targeting any one area
this is about lifting our game as a
country and if i made from um
ben gibson of wabc in new york um does
the administration
support congestion charging in new york
city and will the administration do
anything for drivers who will ultimately
pay that premium
so this is a decision uh for the the
different parties that are all involved
in that our responsibility mostly has to
do
uh with the environmental assessment uh
process that that goes on
we're certainly very interested to to
see that process unfold
and you know we think uh different
solutions work differently for different
parts of the country it's not an example
of something that's
uh best designed here in washington and
then imposed on local communities but
obviously there's a real challenge with
congestion there and real revenue
opportunity as well
okay thank you mr secretary thanks very
much real honor to be here we'll have
him invite him back
i'm good thank you all right pete boot
edge edge heading out
[Laughter]
i was a little concerned when i saw him
deputized to uh the backup easter bunny
but uh
i'm counting on i'm counting on you all
to treat him well the indoctrination we
agreed upon
okay thank you so much thank you real
quick thanks to chris nevers as well as
gregory leskowski for signing up on my
website
dwayne campbell also will always be the
bunny in our eyes
so um a couple of items for you just
while we are wrapping up the week
as you know the administration's
admitted to congress
president biden's discretionary funding
request for fiscal year
2022. i know we did a call this morning
but just to give
you all a little bit more from here as
congress prepares to begin the annual
appropriations process
the request lays out the president's
discretionary funding recommendations
across a wide range of policy areas and
outlines a strategy for reinvesting in
the foundations of our country's
resilience and strength
the request which represents only one
element of the administration's broader
agenda
includes major investments proposed
investments i should say in k-12
education cutting-edge medical research
housing
civil rights and a range of other
priorities that are vital to our future
later this spring we will release the
president's
full budget which will present a unified
comprehensive plan to address the
overlapping crises we face in a fiscally
and economically
responsible way and that will also
include a number of the proposals you've
seen him introduce over the last
uh well the big proposal he just
introduced and other proposals that he
will introduce between now and then
our country is confronting historic
crises a pandemic an economic downturn
climate change and a reckoning on racial
injustice
at the same time we're also inheriting a
legacy of chronic underinvestment in our
view
and priorities that are vital remember
that the white house budget is really
more of a political document
so the president is focused on reversing
this trend and reinvesting in the
foundations of our strength
and this process provides another
opportunity to do that
and so the funding proposal is an
indication of our priorities you may
have also noticed another flag flying
above the white house
today in keeping with the president and
the first lady's commitment
to honor the sacrifices of all those who
serve including veterans their families
caregivers and survivors the president
first lady have restored the
pow mia flag to its original location on
top of the white house residents
in a true display of bipartisanship
senators hassan
warren and cotton wrote to the president
at the beginning of the administration
requesting the pow mia flag fly high
above the residence
this follows passage of a bipartisan
bipartisan legislation in 2019
led by those same senators which
requires the flag to be displayed
whenever the american flag flies on
federal buildings
today also happens to be national former
prisoner of war recognition day
a day when we remember and honor those
who were in captivity and service to our
nation
and recognize those who awaited their
return
i have two more items one of them is a
week ahead
the semiconductor summit of great
interest to many of you i know
on monday afternoon following president
biden's release of
uh his uh america let's see hold on uh
not on on monday afternoon uh national
security adviser jake sullivan and nac
director brian diese will host a virtual
ceo summit on semiconductor and supply
chain resilience
to discuss both the american jobs plan
as well as steps to strengthen the
resilience of american supply chains
for semiconductors and other key areas
something we discuss in here
quite frequently they will also be
joined by secretary of commerce gina
ramondo
who has been one of the leading voices
in the administration we provided a list
to the pool of the attendees or the
companies that will be represented at
that which you should all have and if
not let us know we will
give it to you directly after the
briefing finally
for the week ahead the president will of
course continue making the case in
public and in meetings with members of
congress for the critical need
to pass the american jobs plan make
historic investments in
infrastructure on monday he will meet
with democratic and republican members
of both the house and senate to discuss
the american jobs plan and the need for
a bold
once-in-a-generation investment in
america to put millions of people
to work i expect we will provide that
list on monday
once attendees are confirmed it will be
bipartisan and bicameral that meeting
as speaker pelosi's office announced
earlier today on tuesday the president
will pay his respects
in a congressional tribute for u.s
capitol police officer william evans as
he lies in honor in the capitol
rotunda later that day he will meet with
members of the congressional black
caucus at the white house
on thursday the president will meet with
members of the congressional asian
pacific american caucus
and on friday the president will welcome
the prime minister of japan as you all
already know
this will be the president's first
in-person visit with a foreign leader
reflect
reflecting the importance of our
bilateral relationship that could be
interesting they will take
some questions after that meeting with
that josh
thanks jen three things real quick first
the discretionary
spending proposal yeah tries to make
investments in the country
that the administration says couldn't be
made because of the 2011
budget control act in the caps on
spending
that deal had to be reached with
republicans i'm curious what gives you
more confidence that an increase in
discretionary spending can be reached
with today's republicans
than the republicans of a decade ago it
can't then it's a political document
first say that any budgetary proposal
including a discretionary proposal that
is not a full budget
is an opportunity to outline the
priorities of the existing
administration
and it is a reflection of the
president's view that
a number of these discretionary programs
were underfunded
over the last several years and
therefore prompted a plus
up and a proposed plus up because if we
are going to address
a range of issues where there is
agreement among republicans as well
that we need to work together to um
you know support additional funding to
to address these various crises in our
country so
i will say we're at the beginning of our
process this is the beginning of what we
know is a
long journey it's meant to give
discretionary guidance
so that uh officials and staffers uh on
the hill
uh the the the former the people who
followed in the footsteps of shalonda
young
uh can get to work that's exactly what
it will do um and we're looking forward
to having those conversations
uh two does the president have any
thoughts on the votes of amazon workers
in alabama
against unionization something he kind
of encouraged them to take that vote
well the president uh has said that
whether to organize a union is
a worker's choice and the national labor
relations board has a process for
ensuring
there is an accurate count of the votes
cast in selection so that we can know
what choice the workers
have made so the president is going to
wait just for your own planning
for the nlrb to finish its process and
declare a result
uh to make a further comment but i will
say broadly
as you know and you alluded to in your
question we know it's very difficult
for workers to make the choice to form a
union that's why the president's
american jobs plan includes the right
the protecting the right to organize act
which would give more workers the
ability to organize and bargain
collectively
for uh with their employees and that's a
fundamental
priority for him something he's fought
for throughout his career
but we will wait for further comment
until the nlrb concludes their
analysis and then north korea's leader
said the country's economic woes right
now are the worst since the families in
the 1990s
does that create any additional security
risks for the us and
are we under any obligation to deal with
a humanitarian crisis
well first i would say that no actions
that we are taking as it relates to
sanctions are meant to be targeted at
the
north korean people they are in the
conditions and the circumstances they're
in because of the actions of their
leadership we continue to work with
international leaders and organizations
to provide humanitarian assistance
something that we believe is important
and vital to do
from a humane standpoint even while we
have issues with their nuclear
aspirations
but this the the we looked at the
pentagon budget
you proposing a modest increase is that
enough to meet the priorities set out by
the administration
since you're facing it increasingly
assertive china
and russia poses a threat to ukraine uh
you're absolutely right stephen we've
spoken of course about our concerns
about exactly those issues
i will say that first that this is a
proposal for
to give guidance to the hill and
hardworking budget staffers on the hill
as they
put together the 2022 excuse me uh
budgetary
plans the focus of the plus up on
defense is meant to address a couple of
issues
over that period of time promoting
diversity and inclusion in the armed
forces fulfilling our commitments to
military
families part of it goes to military and
civilian pay increases or that's what
proposed is proposed
prioritizing defense investments in
climate resilience and energy
efficiency we believe it provides a
robust funding level for the military
forces
needed to deter war and ensure nation
security is grounded in the
administration's interim national
security
guidance but again there will be a full
budget
later this spring that will be proposed
by this white house secondly
china has been conducting military
exercises around taiwan
how do you interpret these moves are you
concerned that they might invade
taiwan um well our
uh first let me say that um
we're not looking as you know uh for
confrontation with china
uh we are our focus and our relationship
is one based on
steep competition we have been clearly
publicly and privately expressed our
concerns our growing concerns about
china's aggression towards
taiwan china has taken increasingly
coercive action to undercut democracy in
taiwan
we've seen a concerning increase in prc
military activity in the taiwan strait
which we believe is potentially
destabilizing so
we are watching that closely i can't
make any other predictions from here of
course the department of defense and
others would be in the lead on
making those assessments go ahead jim
thank you
the president's commission on expanding
the supreme court is out we know he's
going to wait for the results
what is the president's view on the of
the calls
for justice breyer to step down
he believes that's a decision justice
breyer will make when it he decides it's
time to no longer serve on the supreme
court
should the groups pushing for him to go
back off
i think i can just speak to what the
president's view is of the
the supreme court justice's ability what
planet will she comment about what those
groups should do
uh when he was sworn in has he had any
conversations with supreme court
justices
not that i'm aware of i'm happy to check
if there's anything we can read out
next week congress gets back you
announced this bike camera bipartisan
meeting you're entering an interesting
phase where
in the house and the senate there is now
a single vote
margin between the two parties and in
essence
one two or three members of your own
party could upend the president's
legislative agenda
how are you guys recalibrating to deal
with this
closer majority or closer margin in both
chambers as you try to get these
incredibly expensive and ambitious
plans passed uh well well first i would
say that um
that that uh what an interesting time to
be in washington and be all of you
um you know our focus has long been
working with democrats and republicans
that is the president's objective
and obviously the close margins make
that a necessity
uh and so when we are inviting when he
is inviting members here
he's inviting not just one wing of a
party not just one wing even of his own
party
he wants to have the discussion about
how we can work together to address
our nation's outdated infrastructure and
rebuilding
our workforce for the future good luck
with that our vantage point and from our
viewpoint
we've seen there have been a number of
republicans uh in the senate i'll give
you more homework but you probably know
this off the top of your head ed
who have supported infrastructure bills
who have supported
you know the wrda bills who have
supported legislation that is consistent
with what the president is proposing and
as secretary buda judge just conveyed
in a lot of the discussions we're having
most of the disagreement
is about some is about the size some
think it's too small some think it's too
big
it's like goldilocks will have those
discussions but also about the pay force
and so those are the conversations it's
not just size it's quality though
the margins in washington um don't
change our our approach because the
president was elected because he was
committed to
working with uh both parties to working
together to address the crisis our
country is facing
go ahead peter thank you very much uh to
follow up on ed's questions about the
supreme court
yeah uh action today president biden
once said in 1983 he thought court
packing was time
he said he thought he had idea when fdr
tried it so why
ask a panel now to go and see well
there's been 38 years since then
the panel is being asked to do a number
of take a number of steps including
the pros and cons sometimes things
change in 38 years they will also be
looking at
the court's role in the constitutional
system the length of service and
turnover of justice on the court
justices on the court
the membership and size of the court and
the court's case selection
rules and practices and the makeup of
this commission which was vital for the
president uh what is
in the year joe biden was born the death
rate from general anesthesia was very
high why does the president support the
use of general anesthesia in 2021 john
okay and then about immigration the us
government is now reportedly spending 60
million dollars a week
to shelter migrant children that adds up
to
3.1 billion dollars in a year where is
that money coming from
well first i would say that as you may
recall the prior administration
requested and received nearly three
billion dollars in supplemental funding
from congress for the uc program back in
2019. that came after the previous
administration had already made multiple
transfers of hundreds of millions
of dollars and our commitment is to
ensuring
hhs has the funds it needs now to safely
and humanely care for children which of
course is resource intensive
we know that there are 200 permanent
shelters around the country
and there are needs related to the
pandemic social
distancing enhanced ventilation and
testing that are
additional needs given the time that
we're living in and
because of the time that we're living in
is there a concern if this is hhs money
that
it is that these shelters at the
washington post says the costs are going
to rise significantly that the shelters
might be draining pandemic response
elsewhere
no no that is not what our concern is um
we uh
it's not how it works either funding for
the pandemic response
i'm just conveying to you what we feel
this cost is and
why it is at the rate it is at this
point in time just one more
uh texas governor greg abbott says that
he asked the biden administration to
shut down the temporary shelter for
migrant kids at the freeman coliseum and
san antonio
because he says he's got information
that children there are being
sexually assaulted is that facility
going to be shut down
well first we take safety and the
well-being of children
in our care very seriously uh hence our
earlier conversation about the funding
spent to keep them safe during
we also are skeptical about anything
greg abbott says
his claims will be looked into and
investigated by the department of health
and human services
currently we have no basis for his call
to shut down
the uh freeman the san antonio freeman
coliseum as an intake site
but we will of course we take these uh
this uh these allegations seriously
and they will be investigated the last
one would just be you said this week
that
why does he get to ask six questions
more efficient and effective and that
you're addressing this in a humane way
that keeps these kids as safe as we
possibly can if these allegations are
true how is that consistent with
what you guys are well again we are
looking into these allegations we take
them seriously and our focus remains on
the safety and well-being
of children hence we're looking into
them and taking it very seriously
go ahead caitlin thank you on the
commission for the supreme court when
president biden first disclosed this
idea i believe he was still a candidate
when he
said this he said he wanted
recommendations as to how to reform the
court system because quote it's getting
out of whack
yet this commission is not going to
actually make recommendations
they will they'll be doing a report 180
date at 180 days that will be released
to the public but it's a report but it's
not them actually making recommendations
to the president
well i'm sure he'll take a look at that
uh report that
this diverse group of members are
putting together thinking through over
the next 180 days and it will
impact his thinking moving forward so
but it won't explicitly say
here is a recommendation from what we've
studied to do xyz
it's meant to be a report and a summary
of their discussions and their findings
i don't know what it will look like and
i'm not going to get ahead of what their
process will be
okay and then all the lawmakers who are
being invited on monday
who picked the group of lawmakers that
are being invited
was it the president the white house
uh you know we these decisions are made
in coordination between
the legislative affairs team and of
course uh with the approval of the
president and who will be invited and i
will just say that
whenever we have the final list this
will be the first of what we envision as
you can see by his schedule next week to
be many meetings and
and many of them bipartisan as well when
is joe biden watching tv though there
doesn't seem to be a lot of time left
for that
part of it or not he's somebody that
we're of course in close touch with
and we look forward to working with as
we move the american jobs plan forward
okay my last question on johnson and
johnson given
just how much money the federal
government has given them and the
president has ordered an additional 100
million doses from them
has he actually spoken with any of the
executives at johnson and johnson
given these uneven numbers of doses that
we're seeing coming in and how slow
they've been
to get an even steady supply of
production
well i would say that our cova
coordinator jeff science and other
members of our coveted team are
typically the appropriate points of
contact with
leaders from any of these companies we
always expected there to be
to be up and down their production we of
course as as you all know because we've
been talking about it
they have taken steps and they've worked
closely with hhs
to work toward fda approval that's
obviously up to up to the fda for the
emergent facility which will
certainly enhance their production
capacity but
we see this as you know our role here is
to
take steps we can from the federal
government uh along the way
to help ensure that we are getting as
much j j
uh supply and doses out to states out to
the american people so that it can
contribute to our
recovery from the pandemic but we always
knew we've known for some time that
there would be ups and downs on the road
but i think also we thought that they
would have a lot more ready by now than
what they have produced i mean
according to the initial federal
contract event it's far different than
what that was supposed to be
understandably there are issues but does
the president feel that this rises to
the level that he should make a phone
call
to someone at johnson johnson to discuss
what's been going on
he's competent in the role that the kova
team plays and we've also been assured
by jonathan johnson that
they remain committed to meeting their
contract of
delivering 100 million doses by the end
of may that's coming up
uh two things um first to follow up on
caitlyn's question about the commission
it is my understanding that the
commission is actively decided
not to make any specific recommendations
for or against the the issues that
they're
examining whether that be term limits on
on
justices or expanding the size of the
court
that that does differ from what the
president seemed to say as a candidate
is is are you suggesting that he wants
the commission to
change that direction and actually come
to him with specific recommendations
i'm only suggesting that he he put
together he asked his team to put
together this commission to reflect a
diversity of viewpoints which it
certainly will and i'm certain i think
the question is
who will ultimately make recommendations
or will it simply be joe biden coming up
himself with what to do
officially begin that he will that will
of course impact his thinking
moving forward but he wants uh smart
legal experts people who have
uh been thinking about these issues for
some for decades
uh to have a discussion and a debate
about it
and and deliver him a report that we
will again uh be delivering to the
public and you all can read once it is
completed and then on afghanistan there
are
reports out about growing frustration
among
the commanders and the military and the
president's generals
about the president's indecision on the
question of
what to do by may 1st what do you what
do you say
what does the president say to uh
you know his uh his uh generals and the
people that are that are dealing with
the situation in afghanistan um
as to why they're we're now just weeks
from
this deadline and and we still don't
have an answer as to which
which way it's going to go whether the
troops are leaving or not well
i knew there was a report with unnamed
sources so we don't know who those
sources are
of course which i know is typically
frustrating to all of you uh but
the president's commitment is to
bringing a responsible
end to the conflict removing our troops
from harm's way and ensuring that
afghanistan
can never again become a haven for
terrorists and
that would threaten the united states or
any of our allies he wants to make that
decision
in close consultation with partners
around the world
with the advice of his national security
team and do it in a way
that ensures we are protecting our
national interests and the safety and
security of our troops
all at the same time where there's
diplomatic negotiations
with the taliban so he has been clear
publicly i think that
that it is operationally challenging to
get troops out by may 1st but i
certainly expect you will hear from him
on what his decision is in advance of
that period of time but is it
responsible for the i mean you talk
about a responsible
management of the situation is it
responsible to
let a deadline like that come within a
matter of days even
perhaps without with the military not
really knowing for sure
what their posture is going to be i can
assure you that
the president's approach is responsible
and that he is taking
the advice the counsel the consultations
of members of his
military leadership members of his
diplomatic leadership
and also our partners and friends around
the world into
into consideration as he's making his
decision and
his view is that's the responsible
approach one last thing that occurred to
me i wouldn't want
a friday to go by without the dog no
no
[Laughter]
didn't seem to have that included in
there for next week it will not be next
week it will not be next week so do
you have anybody i think you said
yesterday the day before you're
still working with the speaker's office
but nothing nothing new to add
nothing new to to report uh and and i
would just remind you that whenever a
date is finalized the invitation would
be officially
issued right from from the speaker's
office so
uh but we are still working through part
of the question about that would be
though
you've obviously now you're stacking up
um things that you need to sell that you
and the white house and the president
need to sell to the american public
you've got the
jobs plan now you've got the budget yeah
when is biden going to do it it should
happen
presidents typically use these moments
of a speech to the congress and
and to the public as an opportunity to
sell this to kind of make the pitch
um are you guys depriving yourselves of
some opportunities to do that by by
delaying this
i promise you we will have something to
sell in the speech
and we will use it for that uh for that
opportunity
go ahead patsy thank you uh john my
question is about u.s global response to
the pandemic
now we know that we've given four
billion dollars to kovacs
there's the initiative with the quad
some vaccine sharing with mexico
um but what we haven't heard from the
administration is a kind of
comprehensive and detailed strategy in
terms of what the us is doing to help
the world
recover from the pandemic not just in
terms of vaccine sharing
but also supporting financing mechanism
or
manufacturing what have you and i know
that you've just appointed the global
covert response coordinator
when can we expect her to be here to
share
the administration's strategy with us
well we're happy to invite her she works
out of the state department
right so i would expect that she might
speak there first if you or a colleague
is over there covering i would say look
that our approach is that the president
remains committed to
playing constructive role in the global
effort to
defeat the virus that includes
contributing
through kovacs it includes obviously
lending
lending doses to canada and mexico it
includes
considering a range of requests that are
coming in from around the world
but as we've also seen this is a very
unpredictable virus
and his first priority is ensuring that
the american
people are vaccinated and that means we
need to plan for supply so that we can
when we know what's most effective for
kids uh that we can plan around
also um different things that come up as
we've seen over the last week or so with
emergent and johnson and johnson
that we we have enough supply and enough
capacity and we've done enough
contingency planning for that
that's our first priority but we will
continue to be uh
work to play constructive will in the
global community i understand that the
strategy is to be oversupplied and over
prepared for domestic needs but at what
point should the administration consider
pivoting
from just focusing on domestic needs and
start responding to global needs
i think when demand slows down and not
every vaccine appointment is taken
is um increasing in terms of their
vaccine policy
well when we are confident in our supply
at home we will share vaccines including
through kovacs
yesterday you mentioned that the
administration is concerned about
russia's increased military presence in
the border with ukraine
can you confirm reporting that the
administration is considering to send
warships
um as a show of support to ukraine in
the region
i would point you to dod for anything
about our military assets
uh go ahead jenny thanks um on the
climate summit i think we're now two
weeks away and i
yeah i asked a couple weeks ago if there
was any uh
plans to have a bilateral with the
chinese president on the sidelines of
it so first has the white house made a
decision on that and then two
do you plan any bilaterals on the
sidelines to conduct any business
outside of the overall climate summit
that's
taking place it's a great question we're
still figuring out what the
additional components or what the format
of the summit will look like
right we've invited about 40 leaders
from around the world so there's
obviously a lot of
scheduling to be done but i expect we
won't have a
final update on that until we get to be
probably within days of the summit
okay so go ahead thank you very much two
questions
um one on ukraine um
you've had a response to solarwinds and
the past election meddling
pending for well ever since we've been
doing this
um but is there is there any concern
that the new challenges from russia are
kind of piling up now
and uh is the administration which is
obviously a new administration
ready for that and as an example
does the administration have ready to go
uh a response if russia were to send
some of those troops or all of them
into ukraine which is obviously not
impossible
um and if you do have a response ready
to go have you communicated it to
the kremlin as a means of deterrence you
would hope
well first i would say that of the
actions that have already been taken
that we've had ongoing reviews about
we've been clear but i will reiterate
there will be consequences
some unseen and some seen we will hope
to have more about those soon i know you
guys are tired of hearing that but
hopefully soon as it relates to
the escalating russian aggressions um in
eastern ukraine
including russia's troop movements on
ukraine's borders
we are of course in close consultation
and working with partners and allies in
the region
uh to assess to share intelligence to
determine what's happening
uh you know and what can be done about
it but i'm not going to get ahead of
that internal
uh diplomatic process have you have you
you made that call as it were to the
kremlin to say you know you do this this
is what's going to happen
try and put them off or not i wouldn't
say that's exactly how it goes down but
uh you know we of course communicate
closely i will say we communicate at
many levels as you know there was a call
that was done at the defense
uh secretary level just last week with
with the russians there was also a call
done by our secretary of state
we of course communicate at many levels
that are even far
below that and of course the president
spoke with the president of ukraine just
last friday so i can assure you
there is ongoing diplomatic engagement
uh between us and another
interesting phone call countries in the
region including russia including
ukraine including our european partners
and allies
who share a number of our concerns about
the aggression of
russian movements on the border thank
you and the other question uh domestic
um on the infrastructure we're on a
scale of one to ten if you could do that
no probably not but try me i always love
yes and no questions
well
this closed captioning is should be
illegal you've been saying consistently
that
it doesn't in a way it doesn't matter
what they do on the hill because
the public supports what the president
is doing and you point to polls
and they do so we don't say it doesn't
matter it's just an impact and there is
a question that i hope your colleagues
on the hill ask a number of republicans
which is
why would they oppose investment in our
nation's infrastructure
when the vast majority of the american
public thinks it's imperative we do
but as the secretary just said the
disagreement is not really about the
need to modernize our nation's
infrastructure it's about the size it's
about the pay force
and we absolutely understand there will
be compromise there will be debate
that's all a part of the process
is a little dangerous to be always
signing the polls though as your
basically all your credibility do you
not think the american people's view is
important as it relates to
what elected officials do on the hill
sure some polls change a lot whereas the
elected officials are elected officials
there's been pretty consistent support
for infrastructure and i think
it's an important point we feel like
it's an important point because when we
talk about bipartisanship
we're talking about how we meet the
needs of the american people
republicans independents democrats
rebuilding bridges is not a democratic
idea
ensuring kids don't have sure about that
to have access to clean water is not a
democratic idea
i don't know broadband access probably
actually impacts more
rural areas that might be leaning more
republican than democratic if you look
at it the maps across the country
so our point is this is addressing not a
political issue
this is addressing a um vital
need in the country that's not that
impacts all of the american people
i think that's a seven a seven
okay fair i don't even know i don't even
know what the rating numbers are about
anymore rob go ahead
we saw the the statement earlier but has
the president been in touch with
buckingham palace number 10
uh about the death of prince philip and
does he have any plans to attend the
funeral
uh he has not uh been in touch directly
himself no
uh we put out a statement in his in his
name and the first lady's name
earlier today i i'm not aware of any
plans at this point in time
um and hunter biden's book is out this
week um
to what extent was the white house the
president
the transition or whatever that timing
might have been involved in vetting its
context
we were not it was a book he wrote
himself
the president and first lady put out a
statement
uh making clear in february i should say
when the book was announced
that uh they're deeply supportive of
their son
sharing his account about his painful
experience seems like an interesting
book exactly what the book
does uh and that they're hopeful that it
can help millions of people who have
struggled with the same challenges the
jimmy kimmel interview is interesting
for a reporter can't be here for the
cover 19 restrictions
um alison harris of news nation um i
believe star families report shows that
almost half of active
duty troops won't get vaccinated against
code 19.
members of congress have sent a letter
because of their hesitation
okay um members of congress have written
to the president urging him to issue
um a waiver of informed consent so that
troops would
be mandatorily vaccinated is that
something the president is considering
would consider
i i certainly think he would refer to
the advice
and view of the secretary of defense so
i'd point you to them for any point of
view on that letter
i think um okay thank you okay
thank you um cbp data said this week
that the number of
unoccupied migrant children crossing the
border unaccompanied microchildren sorry
had increased 100
from february to march if these numbers
continue to rise is their point that the
administration
would consider reversing or modifying
the policy of
accepting all unaccompanied migrant
migrants under using tender 42
authorities
would we would we no longer accept just
so i understand the question
children who are under 18.
i would say one are our the reason for
accepting uh these children is that we
feel it is not
the humane step to send these kids back
on their treacherous journey you know
the other thing is
there's a seasonality to those crossings
and this is the peak so it also
again as i said before it's like if the
dow goes up three percent today and i go
do you know what the dow is going to
look like if it goes up three percent
every day for the next 30 days
like well but that's not the way that it
works and then just one more question on
amazon
the president supports the pro act but
how is he expected to get through
congress particularly if infrastructure
is not done under reconciliation
how does he expect to get the pro-act
passed through congress he it is
something that he certainly strongly
supports and it's consistent
with his advocacy for um the ability
and rights of workers to organize uh i
don't have anything on the legislative
strategy
and and how what that will look like
moving forward i'd certainly point you
to the hill on that
thank you go ahead in the back thanks
jen i want to ask you about the case of
a ten-year-old nicaraguan boy who was
videos went viral when he was seen
walking the desert by himself saying
that he had been dumped by the group
that he was with
through our reporting we now know that
this child had been deported with his
mom days prior
his mom is kidnapped in mexico he was
able to free himself
through a family member who paid ransom
and that's how he ended up back in the
u.s
so i have two questions for you on that
one why does the u.s government continue
to deport these people back to mexico to
dangerous situations and not to their
countries
of origin and the second question is the
president
back in october of 2020 in a
conversation with the univision said
that he would grant
deportation moratorium to nicaraguans as
well as
well as venezuelans and cubans that
happen for those two other groups and
not for nicaraguan so you have an update
on that and why that hasn't happened
i don't have an update on the second i'm
happy to check and see
with our diplomatic team what the status
is and if there's any particular update
i would say in terms of deportation it's
handled as you know in a case-by-case
basis
i would have to look into the specific
details of this case
department of homeland security might
have more specifics if they can
share them on why they were sent back
directly to mexico but
it's not just this family all the
families are being sent right back to
mexico and not to their home country so
you know why
i don't have any more information and
they're all handled in case by case we
don't
typically speak about each case given
privacy concerns but i can see if
there's more we can share on this
particular case
let me ask you what happened earlier in
the week when the president of el
salvador did not welcome and did not
want to meet with
mr suniga what do you make of that and
how can you work with that government if
those relationships seem fractured in a
way well
you're right that when special envoy
zuniga was um
in um el salvador he did not meet with
the president
but he did have productive meetings with
the foreign minister other senior
officials such as
the attorney general oas representatives
members of civil society private sector
leaders
and others so we felt it was still quite
a constructive trip
these meetings in our view lay the
foundation to build on the already
strong bilateral
dialogue we have with the administration
at all levels and we'll continue it from
here can you move forward without
the president being involved the
president of that i don't think they're
predicting he won't be involved
he just didn't have a meeting when uh
ricardo zuniga was in el salvador in the
last trip but he had a number of other
constructive meetings which we feel are
a strong basis
and foundation for moving forward go
ahead in the back
thank you do you see any changes in the
chinese behavior or the approach
of which the pride industry is asking
china to do that
sorry the masks make it hard sometimes
to hear and i know you're all the way in
the back
do we see changes do we say one more
time yeah you have reached out to
chinese even president has spoken the
chinese president
there have been several rounds of talks
of of a phone with the chinese do you
see
any changes in the chinese behavior or
the approach to address your concerns
well i would say we're less than 100
days in to our administration
right what we can control is how we
approach our relationship with china
we see it as one that is about
competition uh not about conflict
and our focus is also on approaching the
relationship from a position of strength
so that includes rebuilding
investing in our workforce at home
things like infrastructure
investment uh ensuring we have broadband
access across our country certainly
we're dealing with a bit of a
construction situation right now if my
mic's picking that up i apologize
in the region and also across europe so
that's how we're approaching it in terms
of assessments of their
changes in behavior i would leave that
to all of you to to assess
how you characterize the response from
the chinese in the first 120 days
i'm not i don't have a new assessment
from here we are approaching this
from a position of patience we're not in
a hurry uh we are working to strengthen
uh our uh our conditions at home better
support our workforce ensure that we are
approaching the relationship from a
position of strength
in your week ahead you said the prime
minister japan will be coming here next
friday yeah
uh can we get this is the first foreign
leader visiting this the white house in
the background
can you give us a sense of what's the
kind of preparation you are having is
there going to be a joint statement or
joint press conference with the foreign
leader i expect they'll have statements
and we'll take some questions as well
while they're here it is one more on
russia follow-up in russia
the bloomberg has said that the review
is over
and you the administration is discussing
potential retaliatory measures at this
stage
can you confirm that is the review over
or you're considering some actions
against russians uh
i can confirm there will be consequences
uh some seen
some unseen and we hope to have more on
that soon thank you
go ahead hi uh thanks i wanted to ask
about the infrastructure plan and sure
uh climate specifically clean energy
who's this guy i don't think i've seen
this guy at least a
summary recently with a few more details
on this but i'm just wondering if you
guys have
the white house has kind of a top line
number for all those credits how it
affects the overall
climate impact of of the plan and um
what role those might play in selling
the plan to some democrats on the left
who have suggested they think the plan
doesn't go far enough on clients
sure well i will say that um
the plan we feel reflects on
the president's view that there is a
profound urgency
and existential threat that we are
facing
from our climate crisis that the climate
crisis is presenting an existential
threat i guess is the more grammatically
correct way to say it
and we believe that uh he wants to take
every opportunity we can
to help address that so the american
jobs plan will
position the united states to meet
president biden's goals of creating a
carbon neutral power sector by 2035
and a clean energy sector by 2050. it
will do that by building modern
sustainable and resilient infrastructure
ensuring clean safe drinking water is a
right and available to all communities
revolutionizing electric vehicle
manufacturing
mobilizing the next generation of
conservation and resilience workers
this this will not be the totality of
what we do to address the climate crisis
in the biden harris administration but
it is certainly an important step and
one that we've had positive response
from from a number of
members but specifically on those on the
clean energy tax credits do you have any
other
again top line numbers or or do you have
any idea when those may be
forthcoming uh and just so i understand
the top line numbers in terms of the
impact of the tax credits
some of the credits you guys want to
extend etc but does the white house have
actual dollar figures for how many
billions of dollars that represents
etcetera
uh we did put out a 25-page fact sheet
if it's not
in there uh we will certainly get you uh
more specifics and we hope to have
um state-by-state details early next
week
what oh he's a new member i'm just
kidding
um what we're going to start doing is
we're going to start
taking a question from a regional
reporter who does not live in washington
can't be here um many of you started
your careers that way so
uh thank you for reminding me um because
i was gonna walk off
hello it's very nice to meet you thanks
for and you are from anchorage alaska
come to us from yes oh boy
great thanks for joining what was that
so this is the white house press corps
uh they won't ask you questions but
uh how can we help you what questions
you have for us today
well thanks for the opportunity uh the
secretary
discussed the cdc limits on cruise ships
but here in alaska
requires that canadian stop and what
does the administration think of those
requests
that's possible oh no did you hit your
new button
oh you didn't hit your mute button did
you that may be on our end
can you hear me now yes apologize for
that i guess we need the echo
first part of your question but uh you
may have to repeat it so we can hear it
okay okay so republicans and democrats
here have requested a temporary
waiver of the rule that that blocks
cruise ships from coming to alaska
without
that canadian stop stop and i was
curious what the administration
thinks of those quests and
well we heard about this earlier from
some of your colleagues here in the
white house briefing not specific to
alaska but the cruise industry in
general
it's certainly an industry that we want
to thrive and we just want to ensure
it is we are reopening capacity
in a safe manner and doing that as
quickly as we can
i will say that we have been working
with senator murkowski and
alaska officials on engaging canada and
finding ways
to assist the cruise ships that's a
process that's ongoing
fortunately i don't have more details
but it is something we are fully aware
of
that we are working with your senators
on to help address
and we certainly recognize the
importance of the cruise ship industry
to the alaska economy
thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it from alaska
okay uh well thank you guys happy wow
have a great weekend
all right there is white house press
secretary jenn
saki answering questions from any number
of different people we heard from
secretary of transportation
pete budege and i like the idea we just
got to get that echo
under control so the construction's
ramping up around me i was going to do
some more voicemails but it's
even if you can't hear it it's is really
annoying to me um so that's going to do
it for today
a bunch of things planned for next week
we're also hoping soon they'll get that
joe biden
address to a joint session of congress
on the calendar i think it's time to do
it i don't really know why they're
waiting
um uh hopefully we will we will know
about that
very very soon all right everybody
thanks for joining me remember follow
subscribe
like troll comment all of that different
stuff
and we'll be back with you very soon